a verdict could come today in the amber
Geiger murder trial as a jury resumes
deliberations this morning the former
Dallas police officer is charged with
shooting and killing Botham Jean in
blossom John rather inside his apartment
last September now she claims she
thought the apartment was her own Omar
Villafranca is at the Frank Crowley
courthouse in Dallas with more on this
story
Omar what's at stake for Amber Geiger
today well Geiger could be found guilty
of murder of manslaughter or found not
guilty of anything if she is found
guilty of murder she could face up to
life in prison if she is found guilty of
manslaughter she could be sentenced up
to 20 years in prison or just probation
this is what we know about the people
who are deciding Geiger's fate the jury
is made up of eight women and four men
five of the jurors are black for
Hispanic two are white and one is Asian
last September Geiger was still in
uniform when she shot both of Sean and
his apartment which was directly above
hers on Friday an emotional Geiger
testified that she mistook his apartment
for her own and thought John was an
intruder her defense team said the
shooting was a result of a series of
horrible mistakes but prosecutor said in
closing arguments Geiger's claimed that
she didn't know she was in the wrong
apartment is absurd deliberations are
expected to kick back up here at 8:30 in
the morning and not only people here in
Dallas in the state's watching a lot of
people in st. Lucia are tuned in
we'll be watching - Omar thank you very
much